from the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion in
Los Angeles California the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences is
proud to present the 52nd annual Academy
Award we're in the closet the door
the Music Center in Los Angeles
California for Oscars 52nd annual show
these crowds have been gathering since
early morning to watch the arrival of
the screens most glamorous figures for
tonight's international event Marsha
Mason the nominee for Best Actress in
Chapter two Sir Alec Guinness Best Actor
Award winner for Bridge on the River
Kwai
Best Supporting Actress nominee for
famous Burt Kramer vs Kramer miss Meryl
Streep longtime Hollywood favorite Cesar
Romero one of city's most popular
escorts
and the staple at all that Cosby Hope
Road pictures Dorothy Lamour Richard
Gere's star of Yanks an American Gigolo
charming and talented actress in one of
tonight's presenters miss sally
kellerman one of Hollywood's finest and
most popular actors Walter Matthau
handsome debonair Douglas Fairbanks Jr
continuing a tradition begun by his
father Douglas Fairbanks senior mr.
Mickey Rooney Best Supporting Actor
candidate for the black stallion
here's Rod Steiger previous Oscar winner
for in the heat of the night Justin
Henry Best Supporting Actor nominee for
Kramer vs Kramer and the youngest
nominee in the long history of the
Academy Awards Sally Fields nominated
for a Best Actress Oscar for Norma Rae
to Best Actress Award winners Goldie
Hawn and Liza Minnelli Miss Hanff or
cactus flower and miss Minnelli for her
performance in cabaret
mr. George Hamilton star of love at
first bite
Best Supporting Actress nominee for her
role in starting over the gorgeous
Candice Bergen and yet another Best
Supporting Actress candidate in Barbara
Barry for breaking away
one of Hollywood's busiest actresses
miss Jill Clayburgh an Oscar nominee for
starting over all tonight on the 52nd
annual Academy Award
with an overture of themes from the
nominees for Best Original Score Star
Trek a motion picture the champ a little
romance The Amityville Horror and ten
here is the oscar-winning composer Henry
Mancini and the Academy Award orchestra
you
you
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences the distinguished writer fay
kanin
good evening and welcome there's
something I probably share with everyone
in this theater and with the 300 million
people in sixty countries who will be
seeing this all over the world I love
the movies like so many
like so many I grew up with them and
when I got my first job in the story
Department of a studio and ate lunch
with Ginger Rogers and Fred Astaire and
Cary Grant and Irene Dunne they happened
to be at different tables but that
didn't matter well I guess I thought I'd
died and gone to heaven and I'm still
not sure I haven't we who work in motion
pictures are very privileged we're part
of a medium that allows us to be
creative to be daring to be aspiring
sometimes even inspiring and every once
in a while to be extraordinary that's
what this evening is about once a year
almost 4000 of us salute our colleagues
for work beautifully and lovingly done
every achievement that's recognized
tonight is a labor of love it's a gift
of caring and commitment from someone
who took a risk who pushed the
boundaries of his or her talent just a
little farther a lot of those early
great film achievements ended up in
basements or at the bottom of the sea
but on a trip I took recently to
Washington and to Europe I walked
through the film archives of our own in
many other countries where I saw
hundreds of thousands of films now
safely stored and cataloged and in Spain
a young man held up this dirty tangle of
celluloid it was an old movie they just
recovered I watched the way he handled
it very gently very lovingly telling me
how they were going to clean it they
were going to mend it
and I realized that movies have become
national treasures to be preserved and
esteemed as much as a nation's art or
its music and at that moment I felt very
proud as I do now for all of us who are
part of what is surely a glorious
heritage thank you very much
and speak I'm speaking of national
treasures it's now my very great
pleasure to turn over the rest of this
evening to one of America's greatest
natural resources the charming the witty
the very attractive Johnny Carson
okay thank you pay thank you ladies and
gentlemen it's very nice to be back
through this here I just happen to have
a Monday night free to uh interest of
time tonight I would like to open by
thanking everybody's mother and father
but I do have a few announcements before
we start the program
first of all Farrah Fawcett often
communicates with alien beings from
another planet Nick Nolte has admitted
that he has fathered a child while
snorkeling and Elvis Presley is alive
and working as a dental hygienist in
Billings Montana I mentioned all this in
case you didn't get to the supermarket
to read this week's National Inquirer
the Pinto of newspapers
as you know this program has a history
in the past of running a tad too long
but this year our producer Howard Koch
assured me that this program tonight is
going to be fast paced and will end
exactly on schedule but I wouldn't go by
Howard last month he bought a summer
home on Washington's Mount st. Helens so
his his timing may be a little suspect
but this year this award show is being
telecast right now to over 60 nations
around the country including around the
world
you miss once in a while
including the Arab states of Syria
Lebanon and Beverly Hills
imagine this program is being watched
right now in some secluded isolated
areas where people sometimes have lost
all human contact and President Carter I
hope you enjoy the show too
as a matter of fact in honor of the
Academy Awards the city of Beverly Hills
tomorrow is holding an opera Oscar sale
that's true for one day only
tomorrow everything on famed Rodeo Drive
will be marked down to retail
and as it as it must be tonight there
will be winners and unfortunately losers
everybody can't win that's why God
created the Hunt Brothers and they the
winners tonight have been tabulated by
the accounting firm of Price Waterhouse
and they are the most trusted people in
America to keep a secret before this
they manage jerry brown's presidential
campaign the winners of course will be
dining at Chasen's after the show
tonight and the losers have been offered
asylum in Egypt by Anwar Sadat as you
know the motion picture industry pradesh
produced a tremendous variety of films
this past year and many of the big ones
were about divorce Manhattan Kramer vs
Kramer starting over it says something
about our times when the only lasting
relationship was the one in La Casa full
who who says they're not writing good
feminine rules anymore
and of course in Kramer vs Kramer Dustin
Hoffman gave another wonderful
performance he is known among his fellow
actors as a perfectionist to give you an
idea what a perfectionist Dustin is
after they completed filming Kramer vs
Kramer he refused to give up the kid to
his real parents which is understandable
eight-year-old Justin is adorable and by
the way I don't you know this but he has
the distinction 8-year old Justin of
being the only Hollywood actor not
mentioned in Britt Ekland memoirs but
they but it's an early it's early in the
year yet uh Bette Midler proved this
year she is not only one of our great
entertainers and singers but a very
talented actress and now Dolly Parton
this year is going to begin her for his
picture and Dolly wants to make a
socially relevant film like Dustin
Hoffman and Meryl Streep did so dolly
begins filming soon memory vs. memory
but
I would like to be around for that bet
custody fight all that jazz like Kramer
received nine nominations tonight
including of course Best Actor and as
you know Roy Scheider played Bob Fosse
and I don't think any of us will forget
that climactic scene in which he's
opened up in the operating room and they
discovered that his ego has spread
throughout his entire body
I'll tell you it
I'll tell you if all that jazz doesn't
win in the Oscars tonight Bob Fosse will
finally get his death wish and as
controversial is that open heart surgery
scene was it's already started a trend
in movie musicals MGM MGM just announced
today they're preparing a new film
called seven vasectomies for Seven
Brothers ladies and gentleman I hope if
you don't mind if I pause a second
during the monologue I am to ask your
help there's a pretty good cross-section
of the Hollywood community here tonight
and if you just forgive me my wife since
I have you all here my wife Joanna's is
decorating our bedroom
and she she won't make her but mine on
the
the wallpaper now this when the
decorator is having a fit and we're all
backed up and I thought if you could
help me out how many of this is I guess
it's called at the Damus flocking
wallpaper and this is kind of a light
greeny stripe how many like the dama
skirt okay thank you thank you very much
looks like we go with the flocking here
look I know you think it's silly I know
you think it's silly to interrupt a big
show like this but a marriage is worth
saving in this time now to get back to
the subject at hand you know every time
there's a motion picture produced
everybody hopes for the best and
sometimes it doesn't work 1941 as you
know was co-produced between Universal
and Columbia the most successful
collaboration since Germany teamed up
with Japan there were some rather
bizarre movie themes this year I cruisin
I think did more for rich Corinthian
leather than Ricardo Montalban and in in
Bertolucci's Luna Jill Clayburgh played
the part of a mother who disciplines her
son with a firm hand and I don't know if
you know it or not but the Muppet movie
worked very hard to get a G rating in
the bed scene with Kermit Miss Piggy had
to keep one loin on the floor this also
was a big year for science fiction Al
Pacino played an honest lawyer an Alan
Alda played an honest senator one of my
favorite pictures was Disney's the black
hole which is up for two awards tonight
and for those of you not familiar the
black hole is a term used in astronomy
to describe an empty void in which
anything that enters is never seen again
those of you in the business know it as
the William Morris Agency
I could not let the evening go by
without a reference to Bo Derek who
created a sensation intend to show you
how far back I go I can remember movies
in which we danced a bolero
I wonder if Ravel knows he would be so
proud and of course now every young lady
in the country wants the Bo Derek look
so they've started cornrowing their hair
and it just shows you through Lee all in
the timing
40 years ago butterfly McQueen wore the
same hairdo and nobody cared it
incidentally I should remind you it's
not in your program there is another
recipient of a special Oscar tonight and
it goes to pop Feeny who applied the
body makeup on Bo Derek and ten the
award will be sent to him at the home
for the chronically aroused
and I think all of Hollywood is thrilled
at the resurgence of Mickey Rooney's
career the fabulous Mickey this year
the fabulous Mickey's you know this year
was nominated for his performance in the
Black Stallion he's currently starring
on Broadway and sugarbabyz and last
month he was on the cover of Life
magazine it just shows you what you can
do one year when you don't get married
of course when Mickey made his pictures
they were all in the glamor days of
Hollywood or the so-called glamor days
when the major studios produced the
films like MGM Columbia Warner Brothers
nowadays you see a motion picture the
opening credits say Warner
Communications in association with the
National Kenny Corporation a subsidiary
of ITT presents a gulf from the Western
film and what's the movie about Jane
Fonda attacking big business so ladies
and gentlemen thank you for inviting me
let's all relax back and watch the show
together thank you
and now ladies and gentlemen to explain
the voting procedures it is my pleasure
to present a young man who grew up in
the industry and whose family name will
forever be a part of our motion picture
heritage mr. Patrick Wayne
good evening it's few of you know me I
thought maybe I tell you a little about
myself tonight but our director Marty
pasetta said nobody carries and besides
that I'm sure you're all dying to hear
these rules I'm about to read to you
it's always been the high point of the
evening for me the voting procedures of
the Academy while seemingly complicated
are really quite simple and time-honored
all active Academy members may vote on
nominations for the five pictures of the
year the nominations are made by members
of each Academy branch for example
writers nominate the outstanding writing
achievements of the Year actors
nominated actors directors now many
directors and so on and so on and so on
and later all the members vote on those
nominations to select the final Awards
and that would be great except that it
doesn't end there we have some
irregularities only three though in the
area of foreign language documentary and
short films only members who attend
comprehensive special screenings may
vote for them and the secret ballots are
sent to the Academy's independent
accountants Price Waterhouse and company
for tabulation the results are known
only to Price Waterhouse and company
until the sealed envelopes are opened
here tonight and guarding those
envelopes are Frank Johnson and Steve
Bill's of Price Waterhouse gentlemen
well ladies and gentlemen looks like we
have our work cut out for us it's gonna
be tough to top that for excitement
and now to present the award for the
outstanding performance by an actress in
a supporting role the gentleman who has
won two Oscars and tonight is nominated
for a third and a delightful lady was
also an Oscar winner
they're both remarkable for their unique
ability to play comedy as well as drama
and tonight work make marks the first
time that they have worked together Jack
Lemmon and Cloris Leachman
you